what made you want to do Ayahuasca I
feel like I'd be terrified terrified
yeah okay that's why I did it because
for one my daughter had done it and the
place she went to was very very high-end
and they really educate you there and
then you do four days in a row but you
know four days in a row of Iowa four
days in a row how much does it cost for
a four day trip of that like six seven
thousand per person yeah this isn't in
the United States in Costa Rica it's
called rhythmia it's like a little
boozier but I wanted that because I
wanted it to be like very safer intimate
really safe you have to see the Medics
office you have to do health forms you
have to eat a certain diet it's very
strict it's a medicine